Robert Pattinson's performance in "The Batman"
is a fascinating look at the darkness that lurks
inside the superhero. But there is one moment
that exposes the pain that Bruce Wayne suffers.
Here is the Bruce Wayne scene in
"The Batman" that went too far.
Fans of Batman are well aware that Bruce
Wayne has a lot of trauma to deal with,
especially when it comes to his family. As a young
boy, his parents are both murdered, leaving him an
orphan. The tragic backstory is just a part of
what makes the character so rich and well-liked.
In Matt Reeves' "The Batman," this aspect of
Bruce Wayne is still a crucial part of his story.
Because of what Bruce goes through growing
up, he desperately wants to stop that from
happening to anyone else and to make Gotham City
a better place. In the new film, fans get to see
Bruce devoted to finding and stopping the Riddler
and ridding the city of corruption. He works with
James Gordon and Selina Kyle to get that job done.
In the end, Bruce is a hero, and it looks like
there is still some hope for Gotham to be better.
But even as a superhero, Bruce certainly isn't
perfect. He's human, with issues that he has
not fully dealt with yet, and this leads him to
make some bad decisions. "The Batman" highlights
these flaws alongside Bruce's strengths, leading
to one scene in the new film in which Bruce
arguably takes a conversation one step too far.
Chances are, you already know that the man who
raises him after his parents' deaths is none
other than his butler, Alfred Pennyworth. Alfred
is a wonderful parental figure, and while Bruce
has some things he definitely needs to work
on, he turns out to be a pretty stand-up guy.
But in "The Batman," the Riddler's schemes hit a
little too close to home for Bruce, causing him
to question everything he thinks he knows about
his father, Thomas Wayne, and in turn, Alfred.
In the first half of the film, Bruce exhibits
signs of carelessness when it comes to his own
wellbeing. Sure, he wears bulletproof armor
and can take care of himself in a fight,
but he also takes unnecessary risks and
doesn't seem to care for much outside of his
"vengeance." With the new mayoral candidate, Bella
Reál [ray-AL], highlighting the need for change on
the ground in Gotham, Alfred brings up the topic
of the Wayne legacy of philanthropy to Bruce.
Alfred tells Bruce that the young man
has no consideration for maintaining
the Wayne family legacy as upstanding
citizens of Gotham, and that all Bruce
cares about is bringing "justice" through Batman.
"He's not trying to inflict his kind of justice.
He's just compelled to do it."
He doesn't even seem to give a
second thought to the idea of Wayne's holdings
and other projects completely falling apart.
Then when Alfred pushes once more, Bruce
responds emotionally, snapping back at Alfred.
While Bruce is likely pushing Alfred away to
keep them both from getting hurt, he does more
damage than he thinks. Alfred's devotion and
love for the Wayne family are probably the
basis of his identity and life. Audiences get a
deeper sense of this in the scene when Bruce is
getting ready to attend the mayor's funeral and
Alfred gives Bruce his Wayne cufflinks to wear.
Bruce questions why Alfred has them as he's
technically not a Wayne. Alfred reveals
that they were a cherished gift from Bruce's
father. Bruce realizes that his father giving
Alfred the cufflinks was a declaration
of Alfred becoming a part of the family.
Bruce doesn't necessarily apologize to Alfred
about the offense in so many words. But he
realizes the truth, that Alfred really is family,
after the Riddler's attempt on Bruce's life almost
kills his devoted father figure. Bruce stays by
Alfred's side in the hospital as he recovers.
Once he wakes up, the two have a very important
conversation about Thomas and the things Bruce
finds out about his father from the Riddler.
"Riddler's latest. It's all about the Waynes."
Ultimately, the scene builds to them
having a touching moment together.
Although Bruce takes his anger and grief a
step too far in the earlier conversation,
he thankfully comes to his
senses by the end of "The Batman"
and makes it clear to Alfred
that they are, in fact, family.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about "The Batman"
are coming soon. Subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a single one.